imagine a sinister six that is
masterminded by Jared Harris's character
in Morbius whose name is dr. Otto
Octavius and I believe the mastermind of
all of this is Adrian Toomes the vulture
internal squabbling this is rogue theory
and we are talking sinister six and it's
jumping ahead from Morbius but that's
where it feels like it's going and also
we're gonna talk about how the Morbius
trailer confirms that that's gonna
happen with me to get sinister of course
is Erik Bosse Tommy becht also great to
be here and marina Mastro's as always
we're also gonna theorize on how the
Eternals are apparently directly
connected to the events of Avengers
endgame you guys have some ideas on that
we do yeah you came prepared this week
unlike every other time and you guys
were also working on some crafts earlier
than I'm very curious to see what it was
he's gonna love our present him you
silly me the new the new Morbius trailer
has a couple of hints that there are
going to be spider-man crossovers
obviously the shot at the end of Michael
Keaton but if we're gonna go ahead and
start seeing you know these different
characters like vulture potentially
crossing it over and we already know
this takes place in a venom universe
- then does that mean that we are going
to see the sinister six the villainous
team Sony has been trying to make a
sinister six movie forever
and rumor has it that they want their
2021 Spider Man movie to be this
sinister six movie so who's on that team
how do they get there what's the team
goal how will it all tie into Morbius
and venom - okay so when you're thinking
about the sinister six you have to think
about who is going to be the mastermind
of it who's gonna be the ringleader yes
I'd cuz there's a lot of spider-man
villains everybody hates spider-man
especially now that Mysterio is
me missus like this villain this guy got
away with it and here's this kid is a
monster does overlap into this universe
because we have that that still frame in
the trailer that's right
spider-man being called a murderer
that's right so it's it's weird how the
Sony verse and the MCU do kind of have
that overlap when it comes to spider-man
movies in spider-man characters well in
this new Morbius trailer we have jared
harris playing a character and we don't
know what his character's name is and my
trailer breakdown of it i thought he
could be the Niko's equivalent but what
if the reason that we don't know his
name yet is he's a really famous
character named imagine a sinister six
that is masterminded by Jared Harris's
character in Morbius whose name is dr.
Otto Octavius and he is leading this new
sinister six and what is their goal well
if we look at Morbius it's a very much a
story about a guy a physician who has to
heal himself it's got this illness
someone who uses this kind of deformity
this supernatural ability to stay alive
and to further advance his powers so
what if Jared Harris character has Otto
Octavius is in a similar boat that he
uses things like external arms these
cybernetic arms that are linked to his
nervous system to help get him through
life and that way he kind of has his
commonality with the young Michael
Morbius who uses vampire powers to get
through his life but that deranged is
his mind and it drives him insane and he
finds other people who have been scarred
by the existence of super heroic events
in this world are you saying Doc Ock was
potentially you know suffered a spinal
injury or something
[Music]
maybe he was in New York when infinity
war was going down or he was trapped
under rubble as the Avengers compound
climb maybe he was part of a trapeze
group yeah that one of them got dusted
while they were holding him by
it was already a doctor and doctor of
the circus every circus has to have a
doctor circus doctors are clowns and
they're ridiculous
they or he was just like in Prague when
that crab was goin down and far from
home so we mentioned Jared Eric says doc
so he is our ringleader of the team so
who else does he reach out to well also
in the son of spider-verse is someone
else who seems to be affected by the
events of supernatural events we got
Cletus Kasady as carnage joining that
team because their mission will be to
get back at one of the superheroes who
they all hate maybe their mission is
killed the Spider Man right well and
what has happened to carnage carnage has
been infected by symbiote right which
they might link to Oh
other things from outer space that come
down here why can't we just have an
earth that was peaceful without all
these crazy fictional sci-fi events
happening they know their events are
fictional so maybe like trumpeting and
beating the drum of the Sinister Six is
JK Simmons who lost his son John Jameson
as the astronaut of that light
foundation spaceship right so he's kind
of their PR machine also joining them
could be two guys from coming who met in
prison
vulture and scorpion who have the reason
to hate Tony Stark as well right and we
know of ultras becoming coming back in
the Morbius movie so we have these four
but if their mission is to kill the
spider-man who's better to kill the
spider-man then the hunter of the most
dangerous game at Kraven the hunter
right so he's joining this team can you
still see him he's writing Doc Ock and
then finally joining this team someone
who knows Peter Parker personally
someone who's had a history of
antagonism with Peter Parker may
feel betrayed now knowing that Peter
Parker spider-man
Flash Thompson as Green Goblin Flash
Thompson Atari Goblin so far from home
had those details of like he's got some
kind of drama going on with his parents
I'm thinking maybe his parents worked
for Oscorp and he's able to get some of
that Tech and he uses that he joins the
team as like the kid version of the team
kid Goblin a kid Goblin but the how will
this tie into venom 2 we see how carnage
could kind of come in maybe characters
like Eddie Brock and Michael Morbius
they kind of seem like anti-heroes I
could see them siding with Peter to help
him fight them in this movie and maybe
vulture thanking Peter for saving his
life in homecoming might join that team
as well so you might see some defections
from this sinister six but I think this
sinister six is people who have all bare
personal heavy scars from all these
superhero attacks Warner together to
kill the spider-man solid team let's see
one two three four five six so that you
got that part and then pretty sinister
Erik I'm gonna give you two rogue E's
that it's pretty solid I would have
given you more but you know I don't know
that I'm feeling kid Goblin okay I am
well you know I can't make it
mmm thank you for not me thank you for
having the restraint I made it in my
head as well now just like kindergarten
Erik and I are gonna have to share some
blocks here without fighting because his
part of his team is part of my team as
well I also gathered six of the Marvel
Universe's and spider-man's own personal
rogues together to create a super team
in this case in my movie there they're
teaming up to steal something I know not
another heist movie yawn we already saw
that in endgame where they had to steal
things these are bad guys stealing
things but there's that there's a twinge
to it there's trying to steal they're
teaming up together in a very loose
alliance they all want a common thing
which is - they're gonna there's going
to be some sort of weapon or technology
that they want to
and they're gonna go their separate ways
so we have a bit of a dangerous liaison
here and I believe the mastermind of all
of this is Adrian Toomes the vulture and
I believe he uses his connections in
prison to record to recruit other bad
guys including the arty we've already
seen him interact with scorpion but I
don't think that's the end of their
interaction so I think he pulls in
scorpion but when you're putting it
together a super team you need to think
of people that are brought in
specifically for their abilities so
you're gonna need an athlete and that's
why I think the next person he takes is
Buffalo Bills quarterback Josh Allen one
force trauma guy that's where you get
the introduction of the Rhino the Rhino
is such a good villain to include in a
movie where there's tons of villains
because you don't need to do much you
just need to have a guy get a resentment
towards spider-man put him in a rhino
suit have me freakishly big there's tons
of actors he could have so much fun with
this he's just the muscle yes he's the
muscle okay so he goes there so next
time my dream team is billionaire
fashion designer turned criminal how
come mostly because I just think that
like if you if you I think he's like a
good character I would include Green
Goblin but I just don't think they've
done the work with Oscorp yet to rush
that storyline I mean where is that
movie because there's feels to me that
there needs to be another movie
introducing Oscorp the Green Goblin
serum and all that before you can have
it be a huge part of a spider-man movie
as much as I did love your theory so
anyway then we have the Hobgoblin going
in and then we just need two more
members of our team which is where I
think I also agree Kraven the hunter has
to come in okay he's the master I mean
he's got super super strong senses of
sight and smell so he's gonna be able to
see problems he's kind of the the man
that goes in and does the the scouting
like he looks around where they have to
steal and then finally the last member
of their team this is where it gets good
at the top of the period does this work
if we stack these like yeah do it
Erik did it already okay sorry but can
you do it like this it's one pyramid six
blocks
so anyway Josh Allen so so Morbius is
also on their team but here's the
problem you assemble this team of
supervillains but you notice something
some of these are more conflicted
villains in the comic books and that's
where an internal Civil War being
can we separate off we have vulture and
Morbius against scorpion and Hobgoblin
and Kraven the hunter and rhinos in the
middle it's not very smart the time I
want mom to be mad and he doesn't want
dad to be mad and he just wants one
Christmas even though everyone says two
Christmases is better and you get more
presents he just wants everyone around
the tree
but eventually he sides with the bad
guys too and then over here we have
spider-man and it's a three-way battle
royale at the end to get this technology
that they're all trying to steal cool
and then these two like can you give
them each the nickname that they would
get in the heist movie yeah okay he's
the killer
let's go he's the wild card yeah he's
the one you don't mess with he's the guy
who's always trying to drink blood he's
the brains look what the spider-man of
the grease the spider-man yeah
Toomes great cool the it feels like the
heist movie part went away also what are
they stealing yeah that's what I have it
I think it's gotta be like Tommy we're
sending you in there this afternoon to
make this [ __ ] oh okay just about a boy
and a girl who love each other no yeah
it's about hearts being stolen literally
there's an organ thief on the loose no I
think like we have to tie it into the
universe so maybe this is the
introduction of Oscorp maybe we get the
International Bosco up through this
movie where they're all racing to steal
this thing that that that Oscorp has
announced this piece of technology I'm
guessing some sort of weapon something
that will make them able to I mean most
of these people that will have been
established are motivated by trying to
prevent the government from having all
of the good technology so that they can
do what they want like even tooms is
disenfranchised scorpions a career
criminal that just wants to sell weapons
so my guess is this is something that
will allow them to continue their
criminal enterprises without
interference from people like spider-man
or the Avengers or any of those other
characters so a weapon that maybe wipes
out super-powered Pia yeah like a super
that can debilitate spider-man or other
or Captain America or anyone else that
we know can be
reference probably won't be seen in
these movies well that's just ice they
just lay down a patch of ice in his
front porch art Tommy you get a full-on
Rogge yeah and then you were snarky at
me but so you get a second this feels
like the rogge that you take from your
dad and that he doesn't talk you for
three weeks no no no good job I'm proud
of you out there today thank you for
telling me to shut up on the baseball
field there's an ice cream cone yeah but
you were never a child so Marina I'm
Benjamin buttoning as we speak my
Dominic Toretto okay my leader
we can't wait I don't like this thing
where we're using Toretto as like this
like household name
the Dominic 9 the 9th is coming out well
Hobbs a child would make it 10 okay he
which you know this is like a huge this
has been said right it's a theory that
exists and I think it's a theory that I
believe so this is our Dominic Toretto
and what is this Dominic Toretto I'm
kind of keep saying his name over I see
what is this Dominic Toretto want more
than family more than honor more than a
fast car is to be a new Avenger right he
his original motivation was to be a
superhero somebody that everybody loved
and he brought illusion and all this
technology just so that he could be seen
as the good guy right and now this is
where he and he messed it up for himself
this is where against a chance to get
that back because everybody hates
spider-man right now
right he can come back and everyone will
be like yes he's a victim this is his
chance to rise and he can be redeemed
right and he is going to do that by
forming a new basically replacement
Avengers group when they're down there
weak right now mm-hmm exactly
okay so Mysterio recruits venom okay
because he's convinced areas known for
lying to people so he convinces venom
that you know he met him has a lot of
integrity as a journalist has a lot of
integrity and the high quality of meat
that he consumes is free-range yeah
Eddie Brock was a pretty intense I get
to the journalist so Mysterio can
basically tell him anything that he
wants like this is your chance to redeem
yourself you can't because I'm redeeming
myself you can redeem yourself come
along with me as we become the
superheroes that we were always meant to
be so he tricks this guy here we are
buddy buddies okay then we already know
the vulture is around also Mysterio
needs his tech but there is gonna be a
jailbreak and it's gonna have scorpion
involved because he's been in prison
with vulture right so they have had time
to plot all of this and the way that
they get out of this prison is with
shocker okay shocker already knows
vulture and but he never went to prison
okay so these guys are in prison this
guy is out of prison so vulture agrees
with Mysterio to do this plan and he's
like I got a guy on the outside he just
calls him on his handphone yo shocks me
ball Chi and that's how they get them
out so here we are we're piling up we're
getting our pyramid okay you can do that
okay and then last but not least I'm
taking Morbius because he's motivated by
an intrinsically good reason so he could
be convinced by Mysterio like look
you're a scientist you're in pursuit of
truth you want to improve yourself to
the point that you drink blood okay so
come with me
we're gonna be the new superheroes that
society needs and they work together for
a time and I think Tommy's right this is
not a pyramid that stands the test of
time
mm-hmm they come together from just long
enough to knock spider-man down it's
that point of the movie when you think
that he's gonna die he's at that low
point right where you think he's he's
done for
but then internal squabbling Knox's
pyramid over whoa yep tommy's blocks I
used them to calm down and then spread
when lives and he actually this time for
real kills Mysterio but everyone is back
on this guy's side because they've seen
how bad these people actually are this
the society and culture is convinced
that they're good until they do
something really bad I don't know if
that is and then they turn on him again
he actually kills Mysterio by lifting
him over his head in a dirty dancing
scene but he walks him he tricks him he
goes to a bridge yeah well they weren't
already out of bridge
where's the nearest bridge marina you're
gonna get one Rogi to start because my
favorite part of your pitch is actually
taking Mysterio's kind of in of I'm
pretending to be a hero and applying it
to the entire force of the Avengers
especially in a moment we're in the MCU
v8 Avengers are unrecognizable
there's no no one's seen Captain America
as far as they know he they listed him
as being deceased an Iron Man I got the
hint Eric just did irony for me so I
would remember the name Iron Man vacuum
man that's right vacuum man is nowhere
to be found so right now there is a
vacuum superhero team so I like that
part I'm confused by some of the rest of
it but my ending what I'm gonna give you
is that if spider-man venom and maybe
let's say Morbius are actually like
these two are the ones that realize that
these guys are bad and it takes these
three to take out these so another
bridge which is the important part we
all get thrown off bridges Stan and
that's how we ascend to the Heaviside
lair it's like cats
our Jellicle ball is leaping off of a
bridge we're talking about suicide huh
I'm not me I'm talking about murder very
different way sexier give him back to me
in the form of a tweet Doc Ock wants to
rock your socks thank God it was socks
[Laughter]
just kidding with the coccyx is
basically Doc Ock is your is your lead
yeah I just hi Tommy can you get off yes
let's see save
mr. six invades spider-man flicks led by
the vulture a change in culture you
won't be wobbling with Hobgoblin come
again oh my god
in disrobe eeeh slowly nude with this
new dude more peon as a Harry Potter
term to become naked Harry Potter's that
I watch that are not sanctioned my tweet
was also four thousand characters long
and morena you've had time new Dominic
Toretto more like mr. Tommy just 17 guys
I think somewhere on here on this table
the sinister six has been formed except
I think you're leaving out Eric your
idea could have used a lizard because
you were all about this thing about
people self-healing using medicine and
you were not thinking about the scaly
among us but who it's time for a new
character like electro who has time for
electro who is a character that should
not get his own movie and only works in
a team situation only if Jamie Foxx
comes back yes on those two from the
Garfield trilogy zoology we had lizard
we had a lecture the Garfield the
sinister six can't can't all be like big
stars some of them need to fall away how
can you get forget the classic otter
I did not alter stupid so somewhere on
this table is the sinister six let us
know which combination you think it is
or if you have a better combination that
makes more sense which is not hard to do
but also real quick before we move on
guys we've got a different thing that we
want to talk to you guys about I'm
really excited to talk to you about it
it's a show that me and Eric are doing
and yeah marina did it well never
Tommy's not invited no it's a show where
we get a little tipsy yeah and we put
way too much effort into answering your
nerdiest questions Eric what are some
questions we've answered so far I've
loved the questions we've answered we
talked about well the one coming out
this weekend is who did Palpatine to get
to raise who when how what a good you
have to be drunk to think about that
yeah we talked about how deadly is hulks
thunderclap we talked about why doesn't
Darth Vader just force choke everyone
why isn't there more force choking in
general in Star Wars well there's a
reason yeah how much doors hammer way
yeah yeah there's this kind of like the
questions that like I wish I had time to
just go on a tangent on and in the blue
dungeon but now like with brands getting
drink we can we can just do a lot of
mythbuster type research apply
real-world logic and history to it and
then scare ourselves with the interest
remember that we recreated Wolverines
claws and there are some demonstrations
that we've mixed with alcohol probably
not the best idea and we get into some
too much information about her personal
lives too because we open the field up
to questions from our viewers and
sometimes they want to know things that
we probably shouldn't talk about yeah we
realized that's a good catchphrase for
the whole show just big question it's
too much information about everything
nerdy but also just about Eric and I and
just you can check it out weekly on
iTunes and also on YouTube and to be
clear again it'll never feature Tommy
Bechtold table disrobe yes there we go
all right we're moving on to how did
endgame
set up the Eternals Marvel released
synopsis for the upcoming Turtles movie
this week and it had an interesting
sentence in it a very interesting
sentence no punctuation yes in Avengers
and following the events of Avengers
endgame an unexpected tragedy forces the
Eternals out of the shadows to reunite
against mankind's most ancient enemy the
deviants so pitch me your theory oh no
I'm game oh it's gonna be the catalyst
for the events of the Eternals I have an
idea okay great okay so Thanos is
technically an eternal okay and he has a
recessive or dominant and whatever you
want to say gene a gene that manifests
him in himself that's deviant which is
why he looks purple at the time in this
in my reality the Eternals actually were
participating in the events of endgame
they were aware and I know that goes
against what you just read but guess
what this is rogue Theory not safe
theory yeah
but the Eternals because they have
superpowers were actually offworld like
Captain Marvel has other things to
attend to human beings are not the only
ones that exist all of these Eternals
were offworld trying to help doing
whatever they're doing using their
powers in other planets and they were
just honestly guys they're just busy and
when Thanos dies when the Avengers
actually kill thanos it went a head chop
or snap the snap gotcha then that is the
catalyst that makes a deviance rat rally
around him because technically he is one
of them and it's like oh just because
he's purple the Eternals reject him oh
just because he wiped out half of all
living things just because of that tiny
thing that he did you guys are gonna
just cast him as this bad guy and they
rally around him and he essentially you
know it might be fantasies like
unintended consequence that he probably
would get a huge kick out of is even
after he's gone he's still causing chaos
because the deviants then decided to
come out of hiding and they're like you
know what we're gonna cause some trouble
and then they're the reasons they start
messing up like all of Earth's stuff The
Avengers are gone and it causes the
Eternals to have to come back because
there are no Avengers active right now
and he's Thanos is essentially the
reason why this all kicks off is cuz he
died and he I think he would love that
the deviants avenging him yeah that's
exactly why I come into this idea that
definitely the death of Thanos has
ramifications cuz it would all right I'm
kind of feeling it somebody else in my
theory the Eternals did stay out of
conflict they but they're still at the
encouragement of one of the Eternals
kind of had like kind of leaned on them
to like no we should we should let this
play out we don't need that to happen so
the first third of this movie the first
act we're kind of just meeting the
eternal isn't getting an understanding
of who they are this movie is
star-studded there's lots of very famous
people in this movie which which is
gonna come in for a second they're not
all making it to the end they're not all
gonna be in the final thing because what
happens when Iron Man snaps away Thanos
and all of his allies unexpectedly one
member of the Eternals dusts because the
person I'm thinking maybe possibly
Richard Madden's character has been
Icarus yeah this has been encouraging
internals to stay out of it
in order to benefit Thanos they think
it's because it's been that like you
know they're just like do no harm do not
interfere he actually has motivation
he's but he's been in league with Thanos
so he's convinced them to stay out of it
so this leads to almost a like knives
out whodunit of like was anyone else
maybe not in league with Thanos but at
least in league with Icarus and like
where they tell me interests not maybe
necessarily knowing what they're doing
but still have some blood on their hands
I have some dust on their hands
if you will and then too as there have
never been more fragmented the deviant
scum is being a manifest their powers
I'm forcing them to have to kind of not
really trust each other but still team
up to stop this thing and there's a big
like you know in the end they they're
able to come together and fight as a
team but it takes them a long time to
really be a cohesive unit again because
they're so devastated by the tragic
unforeseen event that we get in that's
the tragic event yes so that is my
Eternals film it's a good tragic event I
rest my case series is more the inciting
incident of the whole thing yes that's
correct
yeah I'm gonna take it okay I'm gonna
take it I mean you buy it for dropped a
bunch of things here so you can just
have everything up dropping three
quarters of one Rogge all right here's
my theory I think the events of
adventures in game have left earth in a
state of like crisis because we find
people gonna want to know who what
sustainer sky did this to us like
imagine if this happened our world we'd
want to know who the space pirate was
right so we find out maybe that he's a
deviant and due to the Kree coming in
maybe they'll say like okay we have a
lot of research about eugenics and
genetic engineering there's a such thing
called deviant because scrolls were
derived they were descendants of the
deviants so they're like there are many
there are thousands amongst you
Earthlings terrence who have this
deviant gene so it creates this crisis
this kind of discriminatory lock these
people out put them in cages and then an
archaeologist who studies ancient
history by the name of dane whitman
looks into the history of the deviant
gene and through his exploration
uncovers the ebony blade which becomes
turns him into the Black Knight and this
blade is kind of like it transports and
makes him unstuck in time to go back to
ancient history to meet the Eternals of
ancient times so he gets to learn about
like the the history of the difference
between the Eternals and the deviants
and how this all began with the
Celestials cetera et cetera and he finds
out that the conflicts of the past
the same in the conflicts of the present
and back in the day it was Eternals
versus deviants us versus them and
people believed like the way that create
the scroll the they believed these
monstrous others are evil when in fact
the twist is the deviants are actually
totally fine
they're totally got a bad name yeah they
just got a bad rap dane Whitman Black
Knight is gonna find out the deviants
are actually great people and their
descendants are just as fine yeah he
helps win this war in favor the deviant
so that they can survive and now in the
past and then the present we go back to
the future we find out the descendants
of these deviants are named mutants so
he's able to start winning this fight
became become the champion of the Marvel
mutants in the modern age and it sets
the stage now for mutants to be
second-class citizens in the modern day
MCU because of their deviant gene
because of their deviant genes I know
it's not exactly comic book Canon but I
think it's part of the history that most
marvellous aren't so passionate about
that I feel like haven't fighting kind
of tweak the history a bit so you're
throwing out there let me get this
straight what I mean I guess you're
throwing out there that the majority
this movie takes place in the deep
distant past yes it's gonna be on
multiple timelines which Kevin Feige and
the Marvel team have kind of hinted at
that it's gonna take place back in
Babylonian era and the Sumerian era back
in ancient Egypt we're gonna jump around
so we're gonna start in the modern era
we're gonna go back we're gonna learn
things about the present time that's
gonna inform how we should look at these
other people that these other people are
just fine they're just different there's
nothing wrong with that
Eric that's thus
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the best road theory we've had
that's a golden Rogi the golden Rogi
you're going to Hollywood throw him off
a bridge
yeah on the back wall is yours for the
rest of the episode it's signed by
forger guys I hate to tell you this the
golden Rogi Eric automatically wins the
entire episode you make a civil-rights
metaphor I'm down that's good Eric to be
clear was their civil rights metaphor in
their crap the golden bogey I stole it
for you my lord
okay fine you can keep it all right okay
can't be unkept oh no message because
the original x-men comics said a civil
rights back exactly as an archaeologist
and brought a blade tour which Eric Dez
told a story about he does keep a blade
on him yeah I don't want that picture
because there is I have a cold sore in
it you will tell that story and wrote
the ER and big question you'll never
know will you watch you can't stop me
from watching yes the kid only my
parents can live at my screen time
guys all right well we all know that
Erik won this episode so one by one each
host has to look directly into the
camera to wink and say give me some
sinister sex okay Erik I wish you hadn't
won now okay
give me some sinister sex quasi straight
yeah give me some sinister sex you got
it this camera okay give me some
sinister sex let's do a quick recap of
bubbles marina just real quick when are
you at 3 in spider-man yeah Tommy got to
stop winking and Eric got to plus
infinity that's so amazing thank you for
going rogue with us thanks to our guest
marina master I'm on Twitter and
Instagram at Marina Masters Tommy Beck
told I'm serving at Gino's East pizzeria
tonight that's true it's true don't come
to my work unless you've got any
problems with yeah you can find me at EA
vas on the channel we this week and
we're gonna go into why scott derrickson
really left the Doctor Strange
multiverse madness movie great that's
fascinating I also remember to check how
big question we're really excited about
this week's episode kind of like making
it our big launch episode even though we
don't like don't forget to subscribe to
the rogue theory podcast me and stay
tuned to the YouTube channel for this
and obviously all those other shows
follow us all on Twitter at new rock
stars find out when all this stuff comes
out and follow me at Phillip Malina on
Twitter and Instagram give me some
sinister sex
[Music]